Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan,
and today, I'm excited to be doing Rawkode
live as we take a look at Gimlet,
a developer platform built around GitOps principles.
To teach us more about Gimlet, we are
joined by its creator and maintainer,
Laszlo Fugas. Hey, man. How are you?
Hey. Hey, David. Thanks for having me. Thanks
for the intro.
Absolutely. My pleasure to have you on today's
session. I'm really excited for this one. I'm
looking forward to just,
you and I, we always have good conversations.
So this is going to be a good
episode today.
Yeah, we don't necessarily see eye to eye
on every topic, but I think that's a
good part of it. So I'm really excited
to be here. Yeah,
hello, everyone. Yeah,
yeah,
always see that as a great thing, though,
right? Because we get to share our own
opinions and as long as we're all wise
enough to share them in a way where
we can have an open mind and learn
together, it doesn't matter if you win or
change someone's opinion, but we broaden our experience
as a whole.
So, yeah, excited is definitely where I am
today.
For anyone who's not aware of you, can
you just tell us a little bit more
about you and what you've been up to?
Sure. So I'm Laszlo Fogash. I'm sitting in
Hungary,
very it's very warm right now, 35 Celsius.
Hey, Alessandro.
And, yeah. So it's end of the week.
We've been busy.
We have relaunched Gimlet's onboarding flow just a
couple of weeks ago and, did a lot
of marketing efforts recently.
So that's what we are up to.
We are a bootstrap company, so it's just
the three of us. So it's not like
a huge venture backed operation
with a
plethora of developers and DevRel people and so
on.
We are bootstrapping,
meaning we are building the the product. I
am sort of the
marketing slash product guy and and trying
to figure out the direction and so on.
There is a React developer
and also Golang, so, like, full stack. He's
building features.
And then there is someone who is working
with clients. So we we do consulting,
Gimlet's related and bespoke consultancy as well. So
like cloud
things
from Terraform to Kubernetes and doing all kinds
of stuff just to, you know, keep the
lights on,
keep the lights on. And they have been
on for more than four years now. So
it's a bit slow doing like this, but
we are default alive. So it's pretty enjoyable,
to be honest, to be in this position.
Awesome. And sense of it. Yeah.
Yeah.
And and and we have Gimlet as our
main product.
It was formed around the GitOps principles.
I started early on with the flux1.0
or or even before that. And,
yeah, flux was amazing. And and
GitOps didn't click for me at first. But
when I've seen it in action with, I
think in the in the Nordics community, in
the cloud native Nordics, there were many early
adopters. And I I I kept fighting them,
like, why is this a good idea? But
then I I definitely joined the the the
bandwagon. And and
it was very obvious from the get go
that the the GitOps is not a full
solution. So it's it's a nice idea.
But, you know, to to make it useful
for your company, you have to build the
workflows and you have to wire things up
the way as your team works. And since
I am doing consulting and I was doing
consulting back then as a single person, like
a solo shop, it was very
obvious that I I I need to build
these components myself as well. And, yeah, I
have a
handful of customers using Gimlet in the Nordics
region, in Copenhagen and nearby.
And, yeah, like, ten, twenty, 30 developers
each. And there's some open source of that
production as well.
Alright. Awesome.
Well, maybe we can dive into
what's
different
with with Gimlet. Right? You've said that you
weren't on board with the idea of GitOps
initially. You kinda slowly came towards the idea.
And, you know, Gimlet
does want to have a differentiator, be a
little bit different. Can you go into that
in more detail and tell people what we're
gonna be looking at today?
Absolutely.
Maybe if you bring my up my screen
Of course. So others can see as well
because we just relaunched the website, which looks
a little bit rough at the moment. But
essentially, we threw thrown out a bunch of
stuff.
I'm just not sure if my screen is
up yet. Yeah. If you just want to
show what you want to show now. There
we go. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Of course. Of
course. So so we actually actually, this looked
much more corporate before and all kinds of
buttons and options and stuff. But we went
really to, you know, just to the to
the core idea.
Yes. You should fire up a cluster on
your laptop and yes, you should start Gimlet
and yes, you should start deploying
from the get go. And what's different?
I think in the Kubernetes ecosystem,
there are many tools which are
sort of centered around the idea of of
an
inventory
of pods and config maps and deployments and
ingresses,
and you see them in tables
without much context. So your so your application
workflows
kind of lost in the picture. You just
see this list of, resources you have. And
then, of course, there are custom resources and
all those complex all that complexity that comes
with it. And with Gimlet, I think you're
gonna see later in the demo is that
everything is centered around,
like, your commits and branches you have.
This is very similar to GitHub, so the
look and feel is kind of what you
get with GitHub's
commit view. And, of course, you have a
real time Kubernetes
view as well
to the to the to the very minimal
thing. So it's not like not like a
full map of all the resources you have.
You have deployments
and pods and and that's it. Basically, there's
a URL where you can click it.
And, yeah, so so it was very early
on. I think this was in focus that
the UI has to be centered around the
developer and their use cases, just a single
repository they are working with. And,
basically, they want to see their CI statuses
like, is my build done?
Is an automatic deploy is done? If I
want to deploy manually to some environment, that
was the key use cases. And, of course,
rollback and so on. And and the other
thing is that that with GitOps is that
it's great. You know, GitOps, I mean, the
flux CDs and the Argo CD approach.
So not necessarily doing Terraform triggered from a
CI pipeline and so on, but more like,
you know, the CD,
like continuous delivery of Kubernetes, YAML. That's the
that kind of definition.
And with GitOps, it was very clear early
on that there
are a lot of details like file structures
and folder structures.
What file goes where, where is my base
customized layer,
how does that come together in a staging
environment and so on. And the whole thing
is basically just a big exercise of copying
files here and there, templating something and writing
to git repositories.
And some
very basic things actually got broken on the
way. So for example,
once you have written into the git
repository,
it's often things are not connected back together.
Like, is my application really deployed? Is the
health check passing?
And all those things you have to,
configure yourself in in in Flexiteam and Argo
as well. And, like,
still today, I think there were some
GitOps skeptic articles
many years ago, like three years ago as
well. And some of those criticisms still stands.
Like like if you go into, like, the
GitOps room on the Kubernetes Slack or the
CNCF Slack,
Like, very often you you face the question,
like, how do I do promotions?
And then somebody comes in, tells, like, how
is my folder structure looks and how do
I move files in between and so on.
And
it's all very basic.
Basically,
we are missing one abstraction level and and
how how to do a smoke test and
and what what what happens after the deployment.
All these things you have to basically glue
together in GitHub Actions or some CI solution
you have. And honestly, we should do better.
And, this is definitely a problem space where,
Gimlet wants to wants to shine.
And
yeah. So so these are the the two
two core, differences where what I wanted to
highlight, and that's where
we have very strong opinions like how things
should be done.
Plus, we are very much into Kubernetes.
Like,
you know, we want to make Kubernetes boring.
That is sort of one of the
north star of the platform engineering
scene and the ecosystem and so on. But
you know what I'm bored of really is
is Kubernetes means.
Like, it's so complex.
It's
it's, you know, it's, it's too steep of
a learning curve, which I actually don't think
it's true,
today.
Of course, you can always go into complexity
and and people have been bad at, you
know, stopping
just that they're good enough with Kubernetes. They
have to do multi cluster failover over service
mesh use cases, but not many people need
those. So actually, with Gimlet, we we just
want to focus on people who who
get introduced to Kubernetes, and they just want
to deploy something. And, they don't care too
much about,
you know, container networking and so on.
So that's Gimlet in a nutshell.
I'm I'm pretty sure I I triggered a
few people.
Did I trigger you?
I don't feel triggered. No. I think I
actually agree with a lot of what you
were saying. So two key points for me,
right, is you you spoke about the status
quo right now with
get ups. Right? The flux CD and Argo
CD. Those are the two most adopted.
I'm I'm gonna say platform, but I don't
mean that they they are platforms. Right? But
those are the two most common tools used
for get ups. But they're building blocks or
primitives, like you said. If you want to
do blue green deployed, if you want to
do automatic remediation, if you want to do
gated deploys, none of this exists. And either
of those tools, you have to then go
use Argo Workflows, you have to go get
flagger. You have to look at the captain
project.
You have to keep leading on more and
more tools. And that's just the common frustration
with everyone I speak to about Kubernetes. It's
like, I just want to run some containers.
I just want to deploy my application. And
then that leads right into your second point,
which I also agreed with.
And the Kubernetes community,
and I'll make myself guilty of this. Right?
We start talking about eBPF and network policies
and fancy deployments,
multi clusters, hybrid architectures.
Yeah. Of course, some of this stuff is
very, very logical for some subset of customers
that are trying to have certain resiliency patterns.
But the majority of people just want some
containers orchestrated on one, two, three nodes, like
not even large clusters. They don't need to
know about falco and all these things. Now,
of course, security is
but everyone has a different risk appetite and
we don't really appreciate it or acknowledge that
enough. And I'd say the vast majority of
people just want to get containers into production
and keep their customers happy. That is it.
So, yeah, not triggered as well.
Actually,
you said a bird like Argo workflows. Like,
I've been I go I go to many
meetups and it's very often I hear that
what kind of big machinery they built with
Argo workflows. And and there were some examples
which were basically just reimplementing
a continuous integration server, which felt like, oh
my god, sure, you have these tools, but
you don't have to do everything yourself. So
so those those definitely not,
the kind of Kubernetes
things that I like. So I, I definitely
want to focus on making it more accessible.
Like, just a month ago or a little
bit actually, it was two months ago, I
was asking on Twitter,
like, you know, the Gartner hype cycle.
Mhmm.
And I just wanted people to place Kubernetes
on it.
And there were a couple of answers that,
hey, Kubernetes is fine. I use it. For
me, it's in the plateau of productivity.
And for for, you know, more like toolmakers
and people who are aware of the of
the grand scheme of things, it's more like
in, you know, in, like,
on the beginning of going up that that
that
plateau.
Yeah. Because
we are we are missing a couple of
building blocks here. We are we are doing
a lot of complexity things. But
eventually,
like, if you reach this this plateau,
like like, I believe I have reached it
for myself and and and many people who
are building these platforms. And and honestly,
I much rather copy a cube CTI command
off of the Internet today than any pseudo
do something on my VM kind of
approach. So so for me, Kubernetes is the
go to place, a go to go to
platform. And I would really hope that we
would have, like, maybe resources like the digital
ocean blog or this this knowledge base like
they built over the years.
And
because
what you did,
like, or maybe do today if you have
a VPS or like a VM,
is that you type, how do I install
Postgres and how do I set, I don't
know, like a max
page size for the kernel?
I have no idea about the the the
page size parameter in ETC for the kernel,
but I just copy
from the DigitalOcean blog and I trust them.
And I I think we we might miss
some of these in Kubernetes or I I
I actually don't
know or don't fully understand, like, why people
see
Kubernetes as complex still. Like, yeah,
I could go on on and on about
this.
Yeah. I mean,
I'll add just a little bit of flavor
to that, but I don't wanna spend too
much time talking about that is specifically. Right?
We've got a really cool product to look
at. But you're you're great again. I
work with a lot of companies adopting Kubernetes.
Yeah. Beer break. That's a good good idea.
Cheers.
Yeah. We agreed to have a beer because
it's a yeah. It's a it's
a long weekend, a very warm one in
Hungary. So yeah.
Exactly.
So, yeah, I worked with a lot of
people adopting Kubernetes and, you know, they're not
coming to me with with difficult problems or
difficult challenges. You know, it's not like, oh,
we want to apply stack comp profiles and
approve our security posture. Like, that never happens.
It's we we changed the conflict map and
our deployment didn't update. Like, what do we
need to do? And it's like, yeah, there
are loads of these little rough edges in
Kubernetes that we need more knowledge bases and
how to guys and just
a place people would just look up and
see how do I fix this? Right? No.
Even if you say adopt a mutable conflict
maps, like even the operation of a plan
of their cluster is much more difficult and
not where it needs to be today.
So, yeah, there are just are loads of
things like that. And I and again, everything
you're saying is right. I'm not triggered.
I'm I'm I'm happy to hear that.
Alright.
Should we jump into the demo then? Yeah.
Let let's let's take a look at Gimlet.
Alright.
So
I will just roughly follow the documentation and
encourage everyone to to retry it because all
you need is just a Kubernetes cluster.
Just that's again,
you know, could be a
a tall order for many.
But we recommend k three d because it's
it just works locally.
So this is how I'm going to kick
things off.
I'm gonna straight into the documentation, gonna do
installation,
launching k three d, which is optional. Of
course, you can use and
other
providers.
And
there is this comment how you launch a
cluster. Usually, this is how you launch a
cluster in our k three d guide. We
tell, like, why to launch the cluster like
this, basically. Could you zoom in three times,
please?
Could you say it again, please? Could you
zoom in three times?
Three times. Yes. Perfect. That's the one.
Alright.
So so this is how you normal launch
a cluster with k three d, and we
basically tell people to disable the built in
ingress controller component because we want to get
ups everything. So that's just
bytes longer than it could be.
The terminal now.
Simple.
And, again, just to just to reiterate on
the previous point made is that if launching
a cluster is this complex, like, that's not
bad. I mean, I've seen a lot worse.
Definitely.
Yeah. Lake K 3 d has a very
handy tool.
Exactly. And the
whole ecosystem, which I believe is super super
mature.
So in commands
like get and describe and so on, you
can get very far.
So we have a cluster and how you
install Gimlet.
One of one of the easiest ways is
just Kubectl apply
a YAML
off GitHub.
What are the alternative options to install? Is
there a Helm chart? Is there
operators? Like, what what's the preferred way?
There is a Helm chart,
which is hosted on GitHub.
It's actually
values are hosted here.
Basically, it's using
a hand chart called one chart. This is
our
general purpose web application
Mhmm. Chart,
which takes a few values
like an image tag,
port, and a few variables
like host.
Like, it's running on local host.
Okay. Cool.
We don't do operators or anything like that.
That has been always
a little bit far from the vision.
Alright. So at this point, it's running in
the cluster.
You can copy
a port forward command.
That's rather
quickly.
And here we are.
Just a initial page.
And the admin key is in the logs.
Currently,
it could be
put into the secret,
which is on the list.
I guess that's just generated randomly on deploy.
Exactly. Exactly. This is just a and it's
only printed until
you you log in first and then then
you set it up. Oh, I forgot to
Yeah. Yeah. Go forward.
Oh, no. My demo is broken. Like, the
first first
first click
is broken.
What you see here, very basic.
You're gonna see your repositories here once you
once you integrated GitHub,
and you have environments,
and there's a built in one. It's called
Profound Sky.
It's a it's a random one, the the
nice random name generator.
So basic
yeah. Go ahead.
Okay. So as you saw, was logged into
the UI for the first time, provided the
admin key. The first two tabs is your
repositories,
which makes sense. Right? It's get ups. We
have to add some sort of repository to
apply to the cluster. But we also see
environments, which means, initially, I'm thinking, okay, Gimlet
supports multiple clusters out of the box. So
is the idea for Gimlet
that you have, like, a control plane cluster
that does it on workloads that runs Gimlet,
and then you attach your workload clusters? Or
would
you run that and the cluster with the
workloads all at the same time?
Again, just due to simplicity,
we tell people to run Gimlet in one
of their clusters, whether that's staging or or
production or preprode.
I run it in the production cluster for
for our Gimlet deployment.
So there is no control plane cluster simply
because of cost considerations.
But, of course, you can you could keep
Gimlet on the control plane cluster.
Okay.
Cool. And and and these these environments
naturally would be called staging production and then
preprode. This is just
this communicates that, yeah, this is just for
it's it's like a sandbox.
Got it. Alright.
Let's do which one should we do first?
Environments or repositories?
GitHub or
cluster.
Let's do cluster.
So Can you zoom in a little bit
on this page, please?
Of course. Yes. Alright. Good.
Yeah. So, again, just the k three d
command if you would need a cluster again.
If you,
So Gimlet has a SaaS version.
So there are some people who have not
started Kubernetes up yet on their laptops.
So they could do that. That's optional.
You definitely have to install the CLI
because there is this command Gimlet environment connect.
It takes the environment, the server, and the
token as a as a parameter. I have
all the all these previous steps, so I
just here.
Do you see the bottom of the screen
as well?
Yeah. It says installing flux.
But yes.
So so Gimlet itself,
all it does is just it has a
dashboard and it writes to git.
And there is
a GitOps controller required to deliver those YAMLs.
And right now, we are heavily,
invested in the flux ecosystem,
primarily because it's much
more modular.
There's no UI. You can, integrate with it
rather easily.
Is that flux one or flux two?
It's flux two,
VR,
I believe, on the generally available version,
two dot one, which was released
yesterday,
should become next week.
Yeah. Because I only went GA like, what,
four weeks ago or something? Five weeks ago,
I think it was. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
Yeah. Yeah. So I've been so obviously, we
are a small company, so sometimes we are
behind versions. So we are not like super
on top all the time. In in this
case, we were very keen on doing the
RCs as well for two to two. And,
yeah, it was very easy to to upgrade
for us. Yeah. I love the the way
the flux two works versus flux one. The
way that the
the sources are all separated from the customizations
and stuff. Like you said, it's very much
love you. And the the OCI support and
the s three bucket support is all really
sweet. So Yes. Yes. Yes.
Yeah.
Now that the environment is connected,
we see a different icon,
some more tabs and some information
there.
If you set up your own environments,
it's actually interesting because now the screen is
so large. If I just zoom out just
a little bit.
Never mind. Never mind. This was not a
CSS issue. I know what's going on. Anyways,
so if you set up your own environments,
can have different, folder structures and, different
amount of git repository. So there is some
flexibility in the boot strapping part of things.
But as of now, we have a connected
environment which maps to a cluster basically.
We have clients where environments are mapped to
namespaces.
It's doable,
not very well documented.
So, I would recommend people to jump on
the or to our Discord
to, you know, to map a namespace to
a Gimlet environment.
And down here, it's basically just Flux statuses.
If it's small, it's just we have two
git repositories,
and these are the latest update times and
when things were applied and synchronized with Flux.
And, of course, you can
dive deeper into the Git repository and customization
statuses.
K. Cool. Yeah. Alright.
Let's integrate GitHub.
There is some text like, no. We're not
gonna steal your passwords. No. We're not gonna
steal your code. We you don't even grant
any any access to us.
Basically,
that's the whole text, and you can install
it under your organization or your personal profile.
I recommend everyone to just use their personal
profile
and only grant access even so even even
if
it's
their own application that we are creating only
grant access to just a couple of repos
while they are evaluating Gimlet.
So I select just
two examples.
System
and
I install and authorize.
Now the permission list is quite excessive,
so that's why I recommend people that
that just take the repositories that, you know,
that you use to just test things out
first. And then once you gain some trust,
I hope this won't be a problem.
K. So this was a GitHub application rather
than throwing around any sort of SSH access
key or or things like that. So
I'm assuming we're gonna see a deeper integration
with GitHub than what we'd see traditionally from
Flux or Argo.
Yes. GitHub, I believe, has a a very
good integration,
approach with the applications
and application and installations, and I could go
on and on about this.
Now we tried,
to integrate with GitLab as well. And,
like, eight months ago, it was working.
However, since we don't have any GitLab customers
at this point,
it was left behind somewhat. So we had
to, you know, have some push to to
bring GitLab up to up to speed.
And honestly, their integration approach is is more
like a big bang approach. Like, they have
an admin token and boom, you give access
to everything. So so I'm yeah. I'm liking
the GitHub way
much better.
Alright. So so if you are a developer,
this is where you live. This is where
you land,
repositories.
I'm an Express JS, or like a Node
JS developer,
and I'm a test application.
I came in here. I see that I
have an environment.
Probably my cluster administrator set it up, or
I did it just with a different hat
on.
And there's no configurations,
no pods running,
nothing.
I just see that it's connected to a
cluster. I I should see things if there
would be things on the cluster.
And down here,
you see branches and commits and whatnot.
And,
basically, this is the point where, you know,
this is an Express JS app. I would
need a Dockerfile,
a Docker container,
maybe integrate with CI somehow,
then a Kubernetes YAML file. And and all
these steps we actually
packed into just this magically colored button.
Internally,
call the magic deploy.
Obviously, you can use all those things. So
you can have a Dockerfile, you can integrate
with CircleCI,
all the CIs out there. But if you
just
want to see Gimlet or you just want
to see Kubernetes for the first time,
you just push deploy on the latest version
or the latest commit.
Okay. So I I wanna make sure I
understood what you're saying there. Right? Are are
you just saying that right now your express
application is just an express application with no
Docker file and no Kubernetes manifest?
%. If I go to GitHub,
it has a package JSON and a Node
JS file saying hello.
Okay. So are you using, like, build packs
under the hood to deploy this application?
Correct. Yes. We are using build packs, and,
this is the image building,
phase.
And here is just the Buildpacks output.
Nice.
Buildpacks,
is nice when it works.
And when it when it doesn't, they tell
you to to create a buildpack configuration file,
but it sort of defeats the purpose in
my my view.
And also,
since everything is running on local host,
if I I suppose you have a Mac
with an Apple
silicon architecture.
For that,
we had to do one of the few,
core tech contributions
to the world that, Buildpacks doesn't work on
ARM.
There we go. So Yes.
So when you when we stop the stream
and you go home and, I don't know,
you play a bit of gaming and then
then you come back to Gimlet,
reported
buildpacks
for the Node. Js ecosystem
to ARM.
So obviously, this won't build everything, but, yeah,
like your node apps.
Okay. Should work. Clarify a couple more things
then. Yep. Okay. So we have a k
three d cluster,
which is running Yes. Gimlet. You added an
environment. Is that environment that you added the
same k three d cluster or an external
cluster?
No.
I I have just a single k three
d cluster.
Okay.
So does the buildpack run
and
the
Gimlet cluster or the environment cluster?
Even they could be the same thing, but
assuming they're not.
Exactly. If you assume it is not, then
it is running in the environment cluster. Okay.
Got it. Cool.
It's
a I think later,
you will see a little bit more, like,
how things are configured.
But, basically, right now, it's one cluster, but
the this image builder is running on the
on the target, like, the deployment target cluster.
And if it's not running there, like the
registry, if it's not running there, you cannot
deploy with this magic button.
Okay. So it builds an image,
configures the deployment, and we're off to the
races. Job done.
Exactly.
And it creates a GitOps commit. So this
is where GitOps coming coming to the picture.
There is a commit
which I could click and I will click
rather soon.
There you will see the whole YAML and
all the things, and you see the flux
state that it has been applied.
And
now you're back in in the repository screen
where you see,
yeah, I had a deployment three minutes ago.
It was by me.
This is the version I pushed.
You can open this up, and, you can
see, like, a little heartbeat of what was
going on,
like the release event and then the actual,
version that was deployed.
Alright. Nice.
And here, this is this is a deployment,
which has a single pod.
We're gonna configure it, guess. That's the classic
scaling example.
We're gonna,
like, take the replicas slider and just increase
it to 10 or something.
And, yeah, you can look at the logs
and whatnot.
And here you can see there is this
little little label,
showing which version is deployed.
And
if we should we make a change in
the, application or should we access the application
or
we can take this wherever from here.
Okay.
So let's talk about this generated commit.
Is that to my express application
or is there a get ops
repository now where you do all of these
automated things?
There is a GitOps repository.
Each environment
has, by convention,
two repositories,
one for application stuff and one for infrastructure
stuff.
Now
how many git repositories, how many folders?
I think people can debate this endlessly.
This is sort of
middle ground that has worked
well for us.
Okay. So can we start by looking at
the Kmet and see what was generated for
us?
%.
Let me just do one technical thing here
to to
you know, you remember that this Profound Sky
was in Gimlet
just when we logged in. It was already
created.
There we didn't have any GitHub access at
that point or nothing.
So at this point, this is this this
is a Git repository, but lives inside Gimlet.
But I can con but I can convert
it to a real environment. And then if
I push this button, it will be thrown
onto GitHub.
And the magic of GitOps and Flux and
everything's gonna reconfigure
itself. It's it's magic. Like like when like
like like like when you update flux,
you just update the version number in the
git repository and it updates itself.
It's like magical.
Well, that's a really interesting pattern actually. Right?
Because one of the challenges with GetOps as
it stands today, right, particularly around flux and
Argo CD,
is that the ability to spin up ephemeral
clusters with preview style environments
is a little bit trickier than it probably
should be because it relies on a real
get repository somewhere and then all of our
environments need certain configuration.
There's loads of little parks that need to
be in the right place.
The idea that Gimlet just runs its own
internal get repository for this stuff and each
environment kind of enables that pattern a lot
easier.
Yeah.
Honestly,
I we had like three or four iterations
on the installer
and how
because it's so many moving parts. I mean,
it's Kubernetes, it's GitOps, it's it's everything.
And
this, by the far, the the the simplest.
And, again, if I push this button,
I convert it to a GitOps environment.
This is the time when it goes to
GitHub, creates the repo, pushes the
manifests,
updates
the manifest to actually flux to point to
this new GitHub
location.
So, actually, we should watch this. There is
a bug actually here that it keeps jumping
back to a deploy status.
Yeah. So now the customization is,
is updating.
Just waiting for some dependency and so on.
So, basically,
at this point, we have these two repositories.
One is applications
where you can see the Express JS test
application, many YAMLs,
from seven minutes ago.
And there is the infrastructure one,
which has a lot more, of of course.
Cool.
So if if you actually jump back to
the deployment,
these now are clickable,
which surprises me even like I
didn't refresh
the page or anything and it just suddenly
just works. But anyways, this was the commit
that was made
for for the deployment.
Deployment
service.
And there is something called the release JSON,
which is a bunch of release information for
Gimlet to
display
the version history efficiently.
Alright. Nice.
Okay. So shall we make a change?
Yes.
We can make two kind of changes. We
can make a configuration change or we can
make an application change.
But let's do
an application change first. Okay?
So
I think I have this one cloned.
Projects.
I should go to Express
JS test app.
Ignore this order for now because these are
previous test
configurations.
But in the Node. Js, we're gonna say
hello,
Rawkode world.
So this is the new version.
Here
on a you
wanted to say something?
Yeah. I was gonna ask if this is
gonna like, because in the first deploy, you
had to push the button. I was wondering,
does it know because you've done it once,
start to automate based on the main branch,
or do we still have to go in
and click the button?
For now, we're gonna click the button,
but we can automate it
in the next step right afterwards.
Okay. Technically technically, we could do the automation.
I just want to finish
this this example.
So you see the commit here on a
normal deployment, which is not running a local
host. A GitHub webhook would have pushed this
commit much sooner.
But if you're local host, you can push
this refresh and, it's gonna appear.
Alright. So this is the latest demo with
Rawkode,
and this is the new one.
And, again, it builds the application.
I still haven't defined any Docker files or
anything or not even Kubernetes YAML, but
we're gonna soon get into that realm
as well.
Now it's trailing and now it's actually you
see the pods flashing.
The version is demo with Rawkode.
Commit was applied.
Actually, I click this,
this is the GitOps commit.
Yeah. Some hashes were updated and yeah. The
image hash was also updated.
Nice.
Kind of what you
would expect.
Alright. And
maybe let's access the application first.
Yeah. I could port forward for now,
or we could do ingress maybe later.
And you were asking if we can automate
the deployment of things.
Now this is the application configuration screen.
So up until this point, everything was default,
but you can take this default and make
it yours.
This is basically just a health chart, and
we have UI rendered on top.
You can start using a real image, not
just this built in registry. You can change
the replicas.
And you wanted to deploy
based on a policy.
Now
I have to tell you bad news because
this
only works
if
if things are more properly set up with
CI integration and so on.
So actually, we are missing a trigger
for this to work in this
in this in this scenario.
Okay.
But if
you
build your own image, like on on GitHub
actions,
And
your CI is running and that there is
a point where your CI,
like, today, maybe, does a Kube CTL apply
or a Helm install or something.
Instead,
there is a Gimlet, GitHub action,
which would speak
or talk back to Gimlet like, hey. There's
a new version.
And then this trigger would work.
Like, hey. There's a tag on
I don't know. We
I got something.
Okay.
Right now,
let me just make a change, like a
configuration change,
to three replicas
and maybe set
an environment variable which is,
I.
And
there is this intermediate format,
which is
basically
parameterizing the ham chart
that we
use by default,
and it takes a few parameters.
If I save this
now this is the first time where application
configuration,
like the the deployment configuration,
is getting into my source code.
Asafo c p h is editing this deployment
config for the Profound Sky environment.
It's placing a single file in your repository.
This is the Gimlet manifest.
It pins down the chart and have some
values, or you could use customized patches or
just raw,
plain Kubernetes manifests.
If I merge this,
my team liked it.
And I go back to to Gimlet.
And
since this is a local, I push this
refresh button.
The pull request is here less than a
minute ago. And if I deploy this guy,
then
remember we changed the replicas to three and
we defined
environment variable.
Okay. Nice.
So I'm assuming this one chart that is
being used is really just
I mean, we've all seen this time and
time again. The way that we deploy an
application to Kubernetes is almost ubiquitous. We have
a deployment, you have a service, you may
have an ingress, there may be a conflict
map, there may be sequence. I'm assuming there's
one chart just has value fails that allow
us to tweak how those all speak to
each other.
Exactly. Very clever.
It's actually it's getting some traction and some
get up stars. And it's
been, you know, it's been out there for
almost four years. And
it's it's one of the easier
to explain
things Gimlet has. So I mean, all of
them charts, they're they're all the same at
the end of the day. But then every
configurable,
and they all regress to the same chart.
Yet we all publish charts uniquely as if
there's some sort of snowflake.
Exactly. Exactly.
And and of course, if you're a post
SQL,
you might have, you know, an setup which
requires very intricate setups.
But most
in most cases, just I don't know. Yeah.
What you said. Yeah. Most people write a
web application that exposes some port that needs
a service, and that's it. Like,
job done. Actually,
I I want to do a plug. So
we have a YAML generator,
which is basically the Helm chart and the
the screen that you've seen.
You can use this online as well. So
this just, changed the replicas to to three
or five. Actually, five. Yeah.
And you can send it to your friend
with a
base 64 encoded values and so on. And
there's a static site option. This is one
of my favorites.
This actually like a this is the all
the parameters it takes.
If
you recall how Netlify works
Mhmm. You set set the build command and
the and the folder.
And basically, this is what we did with
the hub chart and the init container.
So Yeah.
Nice.
That's that's Can you go back to the
web app for a second? Yeah. Yeah. Of
course. Because I see no. They're on your
generator.
There was a pot disruption budget. Right?
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Sorry. Where should I go? Should I go
to the generator? Yeah. It was on your
generator. I just noticed the part disruption budget.
Oh, that's fancy.
Yeah. I don't see a lot of people
deploying them, but that's a nice a nice
little toggle button that just makes it work.
Yeah.
As I told you, we we operate many
things for our customers.
So things we need are in here.
So here's the here's the secret self soft
question. Right? Your spread pods across nodes is
that
pod topology spread constraint or is it affinities?
I think the first one, but I don't
recall. So how about I turn it off?
I put it guy and put it here,
and and I turn it on
and copy.
Start a new one.
Oh, this is something that people can't see
very well.
But,
how do I do?
Reopen the tutorial. Yeah. And please let let
me scroll.
This was the off and this is the
on.
This
is a bug.
Yeah. I don't think it's actually adding.
It doesn't add anything. It's it's perhaps because
of the replica count. Oh, yeah. Perhaps.
Oh, man.
At least we found something useful today.
Well, is this open source? Can people contribute?
Exactly.
We
should have a test, a unit test for
this.
Right. So we need someone to fix the
bug and someone to write an open policy.
There we go. Exactly. So tests.
I don't know, man.
Yeah. I I I need to check this.
Something is off. Maybe there is some extra
requirement.
Jump into templates and then let's open deployment
dot yaml. Exactly. Deployment
yaml
and then
See what we got.
How how is it called?
Affinity or something? Yeah. There would either be
an affinity or a spread constraint.
Put affinity,
spread of those nodes. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. Based on these labels.
Yeah.
So this should be I will make my
first contribution to your chart this evening. Thank
you. Thank you.
Because there's a really nice new feature. Oh,
I guess it depends on which versions of
Kubernetes you wanna support with the one chart.
Right? And Kubernetes one twenty six pod pod
topology spread constraints were added, which allows you
to
replace all the old affinity stuff that we
used to use to get at one per
node. The problem with one per node is
that if you get one on it and
you need four and there's three nodes, you
can't schedule the fourth. But with pod topology
spread constraints, you can actually it will put
one on as many nodes are possible and
then spread them again and again and again.
So it layers them. Uh-huh.
Cool. Uh-huh.
Yeah. This was added two years ago. So,
yeah, definitely not not one twenty six. Anyway,
let's let's let's go back to the good
stuff. So Alright.
Yeah.
Yeah. So so as as a as like
a developer, you can roll back and you
can set up your integrations with Git and
and so on and
all kinds of stuff actually.
But this is the core.
So
like the view and and and, you know,
like the
the field of things.
Yeah. Very nice.
And, of course, if you're a cluster administrator,
we have like a marketplace kind of thing,
like all GitOps bagged.
Yeah. It's it's all GitOps bagged. So it's
not like when you you know, you go
to DigitalOcean, I think you you click one
click deploy or one click applications.
It installs it. But what happens afterwards?
That that's a question mark. Like, how do
you keep it up to date and so
on?
And since this is GitOps,
all these components
are just community ham charts.
Like, actually,
I don't have anything special here, but maybe
I'm gonna deploy NGINX just just so you
can see it. But we have hand releases
repositories.
And, yeah, let me enable NGINX.
There is, like, a one pager, like, what
you can do with it.
Enable.
And
we don't expose much of the, you
know, the the
wide options of all the Helm charts.
What we have a knowledge base entry for
and what we support is like a yeah.
It's mandatory.
We'll suppose and you can use these you
can extend,
these
ham chart values in git.
So
now what is being placed into this repository
is, regular
flux CRDs
like helm release.
And you can extend
these values. We will not break it. We
will not lose it. There is like a
three way merge
going on every time you we we we
update these. So so you could have custom
configurations in here.
But if your
peer
approved this and merge it,
Then, of course, flux going to
pull it down, install, and
it is visible somewhat again in this
let me just push a refresh
in this this view. So now
this is
pointing to the latest commit,
and
there should be a message here
that what why is it waiting
right now. But, yeah, you can deploy components
like this. And now that you have an
ingress controller, of course, the world opens up
and you have cert manager.
And,
honestly, just by
Gimlet just puts YAMLs into a Git repository
and builds on brilliant components and
brilliant custom or Kubernetes
resources.
And just by this very thin feature set,
we can support
basically,
yeah,
all the needs that a
small medium company needs.
Of course, whenever you just grow out of
Gimlet,
you jump into these repositories
and
you you make modifications
to the infrastructure components as you please.
For the developer part, we have a workflow.
People might like it, might not not like
it. And, yeah, they can
decide for themselves. And and I really encourage
everybody to to jump on onto the website
because
it's really all it takes is k three
d and kubectl.
Yeah.
Awesome. Nice.
Alright. Let me pop this over. Is it
demo done yet? Alright. Okay. Cool. I think
yeah. I I think at least until we
have more topics to discuss, I think. Yeah.
Yeah. I I like that.
What I like about Gimlet is this hooking
into the open source ecosystem.
It's just in flux under the hood, but
is then,
you know, you you kind of appreciate that
flux as just a primitive. It's not a
platform,
and it requires a lot more
work from developer teams beyond that. And Gimlet
seems to just be sitting on top of
that and say, well, let's make this easier.
And so I like like that we I
can't believe you gave that thirty seconds at
the end of marketplace. Right? But that's a
huge feature. Like, again, for people that just
want to get stuff deployed to Kubernetes, they
want to get Kida involved. They want to
have an ingress controller. They they want to
deploy a post grids, whatever that might be.
They there's no framework that can do that.
Those things don't exist in the marketplace just
now, then someone can just go and add
it as an open source contribution.
So we're building,
you know,
an entire product that the community can benefit
from that makes life easier for the people
that don't wanna be in the nagery all
day.
I like that.
The UI and the syncing and all of
that is really cool too.
And using Buildpacks. It's very cool. I like
Thank you. Thank you.
Yeah. So so you mentioned Keda and
you install Keda. It just went, you know,
just graduated
in CSCF. And
so
I set up Ketaph for the fifth time
for in the past two years or something.
And the use case was like, hey, I
have a queue.
I need to have a worker processing just
one unit unit
of the queue.
And they should auto scale this. And this
is a very complex thing.
And I told the guy,
this is gonna be fun. Like, join me,
screen share. We were done in an hour.
And and this is when I when I
say that Kubernetes is, like,
crazy major
in some areas, of course, and we are
lacking a bunch of things elsewhere.
But but as you said, like, from from
those marketplace,
that's once one building block. I would really
like if Gimlet could be the content place
as well, where people could get this operational
knowledge.
Hey, I need SSL. Hey, I need an
auto scale job with a ready SKU.
All these things like what Digital Ocean did,
I mentioned earlier. So that's definitely part of
the vision.
But we are a bootstrap company and, yeah,
life is always in the way and so
on. So yeah.
Yeah. I mean, every time I talk about
Kubernetes at a conference, right, there's always the
people to see it, but there's a lot
of complexity.
And what if you don't need that complexity?
And my answer to that these days, right,
is that Kubernetes is what? Seven years old,
a lot of fat older than that. Right?
It's got to the point where it's almost
ubiquitous if people are deploying web containers. So
now you've got a choice as a small
organization.
Either use the thing that everyone else is
using or
you just use Docker or some other tool
that's not as complicated however because everyone else
is using Kubernetes.
All the evolution is happening here. All the
contingencies are happening here. You're gonna lose out
on tools like KEDA and Captain, Gimlet,
all of these things. Monitoring is drastically easier
with Kubernetes because you can just install Kube
Prometheus. Right?
So you sacrifice all that stuff and yes,
there is a bit of complexity,
but we're fortunate enough to have people like
you and others in this space who are
building tools to make this easier for the
people that just want to get shit done.
And I think that's really cool. So Kubernetes
has complex,
but it's worth it to take advantage of
all these amazing evolutions.
David, you're studying saying this better than I
am. So
thank
you for all this. I'm taking notes and
I'm gonna watch the recording and put all
this on the marketing page. So thank you
for this wonderful
summary.
Alright. Well, before we finish up, why don't
you tell us you know, you've mentioned division
of Gimlet a couple of times. So maybe
tell us what's coming next, what he's working
on, what's exciting.
Yeah. What what's the future of Gimlet?
Many things are exciting.
Right now, I am
honestly,
we are getting Google searches on
things like how do I deploy static site
on Kubernetes.
Like, if we've wrote a static site blog
post in April and that's the highest performing
one.
Also, the CML generator you've seen is is
also on the top three
from where we get we are getting traffic.
So
it's not exciting from
the product product's perspective, but it's exciting from
the business's perspective that that we should funnel
in all those people and maybe widening this
this audience that that could come to Kubernetes.
So
definitely,
that's one focus area of mine
to
to help these people and and really,
yeah, help them and, you know, like, getting
adoption and and users and so on. And
obviously, on the product side, there's so many
things, we can do and we probably should
do, like,
like application troubleshooting,
like, if the pod is in crash loop,
like, what to do,
like, either with with content pieces or, like,
well placed warnings.
I don't wanna go, like, a like, %
in, like there are startups on this niche
alone. So I don't want to do all
that, but at least covering the basics because
I think we should do a lot more
than what we do today. So that's definitely
an interest area.
And
then comes the the brilliant use case of,
you know, if you could provision
cloud resources like an SQL database or a
cloud Redis instance
with cross plane or,
we actually had something working with the Terraform
controller.
But now sort of not
not not prioritizing
that too much at the moment.
Yeah. So so those are those are like,
I'm an engineer and and I just love
that use case. Then we have it working
and it's super simple and it just comes
down again
us creating a YAML file in a git
repository
and the wonderful ecosystem of Kubernetes. All those
controllers just
just work. So I I just love that.
So most likely we're gonna do
marketing and and and nailing
the developer
workflows and some observability
and troubleshooting.
I think that's that's very
much in focus right now. Polishing
the big things we have, filling in the
gaps because we have gaps.
Alright.
And lastly, if people want to get involved,
they want to contribute, or they would just
want to follow you for all of your
takes on Kubernetes and complexity,
Where do they go? They
go to Gimlet. And
launch k three d and launch Gimlet. That's
that's that's the most important because we are
we are so hungry for feedback. And we
have a Discord channel. You can find that
on the on Gimlet.
We have Twitter, Laslow CPH,
and
we are on YouTube live streaming and hoping
to
pop up, yeah, everywhere where people are, KCDs.
We are going to Austria in September
25.
Sadly, we we have to miss Sivo Navigate.
That's just not good timing wise and yeah.
All kinds of things.
But, yes, come find us on Twitter, Gimlet
underscore
and Laslow CPH.
And also GitHub.
Yeah. Everywhere.
Alright. Just go to Google, search for Laslow
and Gimlet. You you won't miss.
Exactly. Exactly. Well, thank you so much for
taking time out of your evening, for joining
me, for having a beer, and for talking
some really cool tech stuff and showing us
an amazing demo.
Thank you very much, David, and all your
really cool summaries. It has has been very
cool. Thank you. Alright. And to everyone watching,
have a great weekend. We'll see you all
soon. Until next time. Bye.